demons and death bats are all well and
good for Avenged Sevenfold but every
metal band has its own mascots and
artwork if you liked hail to the king
the dungeon crawler based on their music
then it's time to get excited for the
upcoming RPG based on Iron Maiden it's
called Iron Maiden legacy of the Beast
and developer roadhouse interactive
describes it as an action-packed free to
play RPG you'll take control of Iron
Maiden's mascot Eddy and use abilities
based on his various forms like the
trooper and the cyborg the official
description reads players explore new
worlds travel through time and battle a
cast of dramatic and engaging characters
drawn from the expansive catalogue of
maidens albums and art gameplay is
enhanced with a soundtrack using songs
spanning the band's entire career
including previously unheard live
recordings of Iron Maiden classics
adapted for the game by engineer Tony
Newton under the close scrutiny of
bassist and founding members Steve
Harris legacy of the beast is coming to
iOS and Android this summer no price has
been announced but six dollars and
sixty-six cents would be pretty
appropriate don't you think in the
meantime you can keep rockin with us at
gamespot